wer hat natürlich noch unterschwellig
andere vorstellen sie möchte ja wie
gesagt die gesamte gesellschaft umbauen
es ist alles so unterschwellig wie du
sagst aber das ist richtig natürlich
auch zum teil linke und linksradikale
kram
die leute aber schon eher an dich
glauben
ich habe das gefühl wir sind jetzt sehr
weit weg von dem aber ich also gut
gebrauchen den toten in der dritten welt
jan fleischhauer ist eine der
polarisierendsten personen
meinung kundtun
[Musik]
dann gehen sie mal höher sein dass nur
noch irgendwelche migrantischen gender
taten die sich darüber gedanken machen
ob denn das da richtig gesetzt wo das
war jetzt aber jetzt haben sie sich
vorher nun waren karl-heinz eine der
prägenden personen von kreis und land
deutschland
wir sind inmitten die hitzewellen in
europa in den usa sind alles klimafolgen
jetzt die überschwemmung in deutschland
für karla ist es natürlich eine frage
von leben und tod am ende geht es ums
überleben es geht um ganz ganz große
globale ungerechtigkeit aber auch in der
krise die uns alle irgendwo betrifft ich
nehme natürlich an weil ich schon so
viel überlebt habe und auch so viel an
endzeit vision das ist dieses mal wieder
nicht so schlimm kommen gott
abgereist
die da oben gegen wieder unten suv ging
elektro-smart veggie partie gegen
mettbrötchen gender sternchen gegen alte
weise meiner freiheit gegen lockdown
hambacher forst gegen kohle wir leben
uns auseinander und müssen doch
irgendwie zusammen klar kommen dabei
möchte ich als psychologe helfen mit der
ersten paar therapie der meinungen keine
ganz echte therapie das ist hoffentlich
klar sondern ein setup indem wir
streiten wollen und zwar unter
psychologische anleitung zusammen mit
zwei gästen deren meinung nicht weiter
auseinander liegen können carla reemtsma
und jan fleischhauer mal schauen ob bei
diesen beiden auch wie bei eigentlich
jeder beziehung irgendwelche
machtspielchen im hintergrund wirken
festgefahrene verhaltensmuster die
annäherung aufhalten ob es vielleicht
fantasien gibt die sich noch nie jemand
getraut hat anzusprechen und vor allem
was ich davon als psychologe ans
tageslicht fördern kann ich bin sehr
gespannt ob uns das gespräch heute in
diese richtung bringt oder vielleicht
werden diese
[Musik]
beiden schön dass ihr da seid herzlich
willkommen carla hallo hallo seid ihr
gerne hier bist du gerne hier ich finde
ich weiß ja noch nicht also
ich gebe es jetzt kommt lust auf streit
auch mitgebracht erst meine neugier auch
also ich habe carla ja nur bislang
könnte ich sie von instagram und
natürlich frei ist der große bewegung
ich war einer der ersten glaube ich in
deutschland die erkannt haben was mit
greta turmberg
das gros wird
natürlich setzt sich auch gegen freies
für fischer
die mittel ein die mir als chronist zur
verfügung stehen also
natürlich auch spott und irgendwann ich
habe gerade gestern garstigen tweet
abgesetzt nerven sich solche twittern
oder sitzen daher unsere nachkommen der
fleischhauer einer von vielen also man
habe ich jetzt das gefühl sagt auch
gerade eigentlich finde es trotzdem
irgendwie schon wichtig und es hat
irgendwie kraft und gleichzeitig gefühl
machst du alles um zu sagen warum das
alles nicht geht und wir das alles nicht
machen können und das wäre zwar wichtig
aber und darum sollten sie heute auch
gehen ich hatte nach der streit
lustigkeit nach der list ausstrahlten
gefragt und wird mich da gerne mit euch
ja ein stück weit reinsteigern zuerst
aber mal uns alle abholen wo stehen wir
wo steht ihr überhaupt tut mir den
gefallen helft einmal mit wir tun den
tisch weg die sessel weg und brauchen
ein bisschen platz für eine kleine
intervention
ganz oft denken menschen beim streit
egal in welcher beziehung dass sie
komplett verstanden worum es geht und
haben dabei nur ihren eigenen standpunkt
verstanden und überhaupt noch nicht aber
nachgedacht das ist der anderen person
vielleicht etwas völlig anderes
jetzt ist es hier so dass carl einen
ziemlich klaren standpunkt mitbringt
während bei jan die sache nicht ganz so
klar ist und deswegen habe ich diese
linie angewandt und mal zu klären wo
steht die eigentliche starten maximal
nahe zusammen und prüfen inwieweit
driften wir eigentlich auseinander wenn
wir mal butter bei die fische geben und
die argumente auf den tisch packen wir
wollen heute darüber reden wie viel ist
uns der klimawandel wird entsprechend
muss es auch um cash wählen wer kann
sich den klimawandel leisten und wer
nicht beziehungsweise das dagegen wirken
also ich kann mir klimaschutz leisten
ich habe gerade eine photovoltaik anlage
auf mein haus in pullach bauen lassen
mit energie speicher von sonnen im
keller
lkw nicht schlecht ich komme ganz gut
durch den tag kann die waschmaschine
durchlaufen und die poolheizung auch
jetzt hat nicht jeder so viel sagt um so
eine photovoltaikanlage zu zahlen plus
wahrscheinlich auch nicht im haus in
münchen polar stehe ich kann's mir das
klar relativ gut verdiene gottlob leute
die auf den euro achten da sieht es
schon anders aus wir haben die höchsten
energiepreise in europa jetzt kann ich
natürlich anfang und sagen okay ist zwar
viel teurer geworden und jetzt geben wir
euch das alles wieder mit irgendwelchen
transfersysteme wieder aber das wird
natürlich relativ komplizierte
veranstaltung du machst leute lässt sich
auch damit so almosen empfängern und da
setzen in der tat meine zweifel stehen
ja als nein stabilen schritt wird
beide direkt das ist eine frage davon
wie wir das organisieren und wenn wir
weiterhin und das tun wir zum beispiel
55 milliarden euro im jahr in fossile
subventionen stecken die wir mit
steuergeldern direkt die klimakrise
anheizen dann ist das ja absurd oder
müssen wir doch da anfangen aufzuhören
mit steuergeldern die klimakrise
anzuhalten und können damit genau dann
so was wie eine energiewende zum
beispiel günstiger machen ich fordere
dass wenn die klimapolitik machen und
das müssen wir machen weil die folgen
sind viel dramatischer als es wenn er
keine klimapolitik machen wir sind
natürlich so organisieren müssen dass
dieses jahr gerecht dass das die
menschen mit geringen einkommen nicht
mehr belastet ich höre die worte ja sie
klingt wie heißt es so schön am theater
sie klingen wurde ich glaube ich dran
also ich glaub nicht daran woran ich
dass wir es hinkriegen dass die leute
die wirklich rechnen müssen am ende
nicht oft zahlen du sprichst immer mal
wieder von einer ökodiktatur nein nein
na ja das habe ich erfolg gelesen der
flirt mit der öko diktatur ist die
dunkle seite da alte halter besonders
was das meint ist wenn ich der meinung
bin was ja einige aktivisten tun der
zeiger steht nicht fünf vor zwölf
sondern grunde zehn nach zwölf und es
bleiben uns nach verschiedenen
rechnungen eins zwei drei jahren auch um
das ruder umzuwerfen wenn ich will ich
diese auffassung bin dann muss ich
eigentlich demokratie als staatsform
entweder ablehnen oder zumindest mal aus
setzt natürlich gibt es auch ganz offen
ausgesprochen von wissenschaftlern in
deutschland wir haben gründe die
demokratie das könnte jetzt erstmal
vorüber gehen nicht leisten dass mein
hund verstanden kann du bist massiven
schritt weitergegangen für unsere kleine
lea ich merke das schon wenn ich nichts
provoziert dass das gerne machen
aktivistinnen wissenschaftler/innen
sagen wir müssen jetzt in 1 23 jahren
irgendwie das ruder rumreißen können wir
das nicht mehr schaffen ich glaube jan
sieht sich ja in dieser rolle als
außenstehender beobachter deswegen hat
er deutlich seltener abgrenzung momente
zu mir als ich zu ihm in dem moment wo
er auf die klimabewegung dinge
projiziert hat die die klimabewegung
selber gar nicht fordert wenn er
irgendwie über eine ökodiktatur spricht
über eine verbotskultur gehabt mit dem
pariser klima abkommen zur einhaltung
als genannten grad grenze verpflichtet
was bedeutet dass welches
emissionsbudget hat deutschland noch da
ist die kommende legislaturperiode die
letzte in der wir tatsächlich das
einleiten können ansonsten ist es
faktisch unmöglich die emissionen so zu
reduzieren wie wir es machen müssen um
die 10 grad ganz einzuhalten so dass dem
ich jetzt mal als gesetz das das so
stimmt dann aber das aber eine
konsequente die konsequenz wäre der sie
auf den demokratischen prozess nicht
mehr vertrauen kann also das stimmt mich
niemand jetzt bei den blick muss ein
schritt zurück denn also ich kenne wenn
sie es tatsächlich ernst meinen würden
mit mit dem pony sagte aber das was ich
glaube das ist ja das ist
das ist das problem aber grundsätzlich
wenn sie es ernst meinen würden dann
könnten sie auch in ganz demokratischen
prozessen maßnahmen beschließen die
genau das tun aber kann wir leben ja
nicht in der idealen welt sondern
deswegen die ich auch die leute
versprechen kann ja es ist egal ist aber
sie versprechen dir und mir so zu sagen
was sie tun werden aber das ist
ich habe habe ich den vorwurf bestehe
hier wo ich hier stehe habe ich dich
irgendwie hab ich hab ich die entwurf
gemacht mit der satz wir leben nicht in
einer idealen welt sollte ja nur
ausdrücken dass ich glaube dass sie
möglicherweise die vernunft ja
über schätzt du streit ist für ein wie
die absoluten legitimes ziel so darüber
er über einige sind wir uns da völlig
einig könnte ja fast wie einen schritt
aufeinander zu gehen
sie hat natürlich noch unterschwellig
andere vorstellen sie möchten gesagt die
gesamte gesellschaft umbauen da sage ich
dann auch leute freunde mit dem
gesellschaft umbauen weil es ist alles
so unterschwellig wie du sagst weil sie
bei freiem fuß in den tweets des
tutorials offen weil das ist richtig
natürlich auch zum teil linke und
linksradikale kram also irgendwie so auf
twitter würde da irgendwas stehen
es ist auch kein wunder dass ich meine
das freilich für fische letztlich eine
vorfeldorganisation der grünen ist ein
verbindet mit der time out hier hatte
ich gerade das gefühl dass das ganze zu
heiß werden könnte und wenn wir zu heiß
streiten dann macht es manchmal sind
dass man ruhe reinbringt jan und carla
wir stehen prompt auf einer grünen linie
das war unbeabsichtigt aber maximal
auseinander was diese linie her gibt es
ein paar zentimeter weiter frei ich
würde euch jetzt gerne ganz bewusst noch
mal zusammen bringen und bräuchte dafür
noch einmal auf jeden kopf schwirren
permanent in welche gedanken ideen
vielleicht auch vorwürfe oder fantasien
rum und oft ist es natürlich ein
riesenchaos da hilft es mal zu versuchen
klar zu sagen was sache
[Musik]
du cristina kahlo
christian
ich hab das übertragen auf zwei pappen
ganz einfache übung wohl jetzt in einem
satz schwarz auf weiß der größte vorwurf
an die andere person zusammengefasst
werden musste
[Musik]
vielleicht fangen wir mit jan an wenn du
dich einmal an dieser wand stellen würde
ist und dein vorwurfs schön für uns hoch
hält mag sie sich übergeben
wird und ich glaube auch schüler und
auch selber einmal vorlesen also ihren
fleischer traut der gesellschaft keine
veränderung zu
als wir die vorwürfe formel 1 muss sich
schon kurz nachdenken was ist denn so
zeigen sodass der grundkonflikt was er
dann ja spannender weise auch gesagt
hättest das stimmt dass das ein vorwurf
ist er stimmt den er auch nicht schlimm
findet anders als ich also ist es so ist
interessant weil diese aussage ja zu
stimmen ich glaube das unterscheidet uns
in der tat das unterscheidet auch wenn
man so will konservativen von linken für
die linken ist die gesellschaft
letztlich ein weißes blatt papier
die ich jederzeit neu formieren kann und
welche geschichte anreize setzt sowohl
die oberrichter entsprechend verhalten
soll während der konservative glaubt
dass gesellschaften in der tat viel
veränderungs resistenter sind als
wiederum die andere politische seite
meint
gesellschaften verändern sich sehr
langsam insofern ist es ein normativer
satz ging ich zunächst unterschreiten
würde ja er beschreibt meine weltsicht
carla wirft ihm vor dass er sich nicht
verändern will und jan sagt dagegen dass
es ganz natürlich das ist menschlich und
damit hat er tatsächlich einen wichtigen
punkt und zwar den sogenannten status
quo bei es gemeint ist dass unser hirn
den fehler macht im status quo zu
bleiben auch und das ist ganz wichtig
wenn uns das eigentlich nicht mehr passt
das heißt sie schließen handyvertrag
oder eine versicherung und lass das dann
einfach weiterlaufen obwohl die preise
vielleicht längst irgendwo anders
niedriger wert ich kümmere mich nicht
mehr darum weil ich im status quo fahren
aber alles was sozusagen dann vielleicht
sagen der damit schwingende vorwurf ist
dass es veränderungen gibt wo ich sage
sie sind
notwendig und wo ich auch sage so die
ungerechtigkeiten sind so verheerend zb
irgendwie so auch das ende der sklaverei
in den usa war zum beispiel auch gewalt
hätte ich dafür könnte es trotzdem und
es waren auch viele leute doch wir
können uns trotzdem darauf einigen dass
es genau richtig war was ich nur sagen
würde ich glaube es gibt veränderungen
die sind gesellschaftlich notwendig und
die frage wie wir das schaffen dort
gewinnen sitze ja bitte jetzt ist
natürlich sozusagen das müssen wir
politisch ausdiskutiert aber es gibt
irgendwie dinge zum beispiel auch
irgendwie so gleichstellung zwischen
mann und frau aus irgendwie passiert
erstmal was mir jeder irgendwie grund
dafür sein kann dann bin ich jetzt sehr
gespannt carla willst du einmal diese
position ein das sitzen nämlich übergibt
das wenn du einverstanden ist ein mal an
dich also der verständlicher formuliert
aber möglicherweise zu kompliziert ich
komme aus der alten linken und dann
waren damals dialektisches denken dh
dass man dinge tut die dann anderes
zufolge haben als man sich vorstellt
also karim zwar glaubt zu sehr an die
wunderbare wirkung des verzicht darauf
aufgefordert dadurch das wogegen sich
streitet gesetzte nicht beabsichtigen
konsequenzen das muss mir abitur für den
satz aber wieder vermehrt jan dieser
vorwurf noch mal kurz in einem einfachen
satz
der einfache satz ist ich glaube nicht
daran dass
wir das klima retten wenn wir uns alle
hier in deutschland riemen reißen
den vorwurf von jahren nichts zu hören
habe so ein bisschen für mich bestätigt
dass ich das gefühl hatte
er hat noch nicht genau verstanden was
eigentlich war sofia und andere akteure
der klimagerechtigkeit bewegung
kritisieren und das gefühl hat man auch
gemerkt da fehlt noch ein verständnis
füreinander also ich hab da was ganz
anderes gedacht ich dachte jetzt geht
irgendwie um so bleibe dürfen hatte kein
fleisch meist im auto fahren es geht
jetzt schon um systemische ihren
verzicht also verbrennung von kohle öl
und gas
jetzt habe ich gefühl muss ich immer da
noch also muss nicht immer noch drüber
nachdenken
der grund ist es doch so dass wir das
gefühl haben wenn wir uns in deutschland
oder in europa einschränken wir würden
damit das klima retten da habe ich
natürlich überhaupt kein zutrauen zu
wenn ich mir die zahlen einfach an gucke
sehe dass china zum beispiel das ist der
größte player so viel co2 emittiert wie
alle anderen industrienationen zusammen
so und dann kommt das argument ja aber
die neben sich darin uns deutschen
vorbild und gar nicht ich war in china
welche nicht ist sich in diesem clip sie
dich an uns deutschen informel im
zweifel hat er unter juden also dieses
argument es tut mir leid aber es ist
einfach quatsch also wir haben das
pariser klima abkommen unterzeichnen und
da ist es wohl mal eine ganz klare
beleben halt in der welt und da gibt es
keine weltregierung das ist erstmal
verantwortung der nationalstaaten zum
beispiel das pariser klimaabkommens
zwischenziele vorzulegen pläne
vorzulegen et cetera dementsprechend ist
deutschland erst war on paper einfach
verpflichtet seine emissionen zu
reduzieren am anfang mit dem pariser
klimaabkommen unabhängig davon was
andere machen gleichzeitig ist doch
dieses runterbrechen auf wer hat denn
jetzt wie viele emissionen einfach
quatsch wir fangen jetzt an so das wäre
ja so als würde jetzt die stadt köln
sagen wir müssen das hier aber gar keine
emissionen einsparen weil berlin ist
doch viel größer und deutschland sowieso
und deswegen müssen wir doch gar nichts
machen deswegen finde ich so also schon
sozusagen dieses verzicht training in
dem kann ich mich anschließen was ich
ausdrücken wollte eben da hat hier
interessanterweise vehement
widersprochen dass ich glaube dass diese
ganze weg des verzichts sehr aus vielen
gründen in die irre führt was ich hier
extrem spannend fand war dass carla
ihren größten vorwurf formuliert und jan
den direkt an nimmt umgekehrt hat er
sohn komplizierten satz gebaut dass man
sich fragt hatte er eigentlich wirklich
konkret ein vorwurf gegen carla an der
hand viel viel viel von dem was ihr sagt
kennt ja sowieso schon von der
gegenseite haben wir sowieso alle schon
öfter gehört und deswegen lasst uns
diesen kreis jetzt mal kurz insofern ein
cut entgegensetzen als dass wir ihn zur
linie malen ich möchte verstehen warum
wir heute da und ihr heute da jeweils
steht wo ihr steht und würde euch jetzt
gerne mal auf die übertrieben gesagt
therapeutische couch legen allerdings
nicht mit mir ich bin ja auch kein
psychotherapeut sondern mit mir nur als
psychologischer begleiter und ihr
schlüpft in die rolle
carla du vielleicht zuerst auf die couch
jan daneben und dann würde ich gerne
dass du versucht herauszufinden wieso
ist sie so geworden wie sie heute ist
und danach tauschen wir haben ja die
ganze zeit ist ein spagat zwischen der
großen weltbühne um diese natürlich
gehen muss um das klima in allen
kontinenten theoretisch auch noch um die
atmosphäre also ein riesending und dann
haben wir aber zwei menschen die
natürlich auch ihre ganz eigene kleine
welt leben die ihren alltag haben und da
wollte ich rein um zu verstehen weil die
beiden ja auch ein bisschen
stellvertretend hier sind für zwei
standpunkte wie seid ihr eigentlich
dahin gekommen was ist eure
vergangenheit die euch zu dem gemacht
hat was ihr heute seid
gab es sowas wie ein
erweckungserlebnis etwas wohl du
angefangen hast doch das zu einem
wesentlichen bestandteil des lebens zu
machen ich glaube ein moment auf jeden
fall der so
wenig am ehesten noch als das bezeichnen
würde ohne dass ich sagen würde es war
jetzt und erweckung swanton
dann geht irgendwie sind die sonne
hoffen
als ich das erste mal in
nordrhein-westfalen in rheine stritten
am tagebau hambach war dann steht man
davor diesem loch und es geht halt ist
so eine kante und es geht halt 400 meter
nach unten man sieht das ende dieses
lochs gar nicht da drin stehen bagger da
ist das schaufelrad höher als das haus
in dem ich wohne also irgendwie so 22
meter und das ist okay ich verstehe was
leute meinen wenn wir sagen wir wollten
einen planeten aus und das alles für so
den dreckigsten energieträger jemals das
war glaube ich so was wohl schon auch
also wenn man so gedacht hat die
dimension ist irgendwie größer als ich
die secondhand shoppen und die
veränderung also das was in gebrauch ist
ein bisschen mehr als das
und gibt dir dein engagement mehr kraft
oder lässt es sich auch nicht
verzweifeln weil du den eindruck hast es
geht eben nicht schnell genug voran ich
glaube sowohl als auch ein teil meines
engagements besteht wirklich auch so
denken wie wissenschaftliche studien
lesen gesetzesentwürfe und irgendwie
einschätzungen dazu
das ist eher der teile der einst zur
vertreibung bringen gleichzeitig gibt es
mir vor allem sozusagen das engagement
in sich in dem was wir tun ganz viel
kraft und die leute mit denen ich das
zusammen tue weil ich weiss man es
irgendwie damit nicht alleine und es
gibt andere leute die sehen denselben
veränderungsdruck das ist wenn man so
will die tragik des politischen
aktivisten sie wissen natürlich was der
richtige weg ist
davon ist wieder war freies verfügte er
letztlich überzeugt und frustriert
feststellen zu müssen dass die meistens
entweder nicht einsehen ist sogar
negieren oder sich dagegen stellen oder
einfach zu bequem sind diesen weg
mitzugehen so ich verstehe auch dass
leute resignieren wenn sie irgendwie
sehen was die neuesten klima berichte
sagen und was die politik irgendwie so
verabschiedet
umfragen aus sehr vielen
unterschiedlichen ländern auch den
reichen industrienationen zeigen dass
gerade die jungen menschen angst haben
das nennt sich kleine anxiety ich habe
angst davor dass sich das klima
verändert und dass das einen einfluss
auf mein leben haben wird gerade die
jungen menschen akzeptieren den
wissenschaftlichen konsens im vergleich
zu den älteren deutlich er und daraus
erwachsen nicht nur ängste sondern auch
wird sorgen und traurigkeit ja mal so
eine breite palette an negativen
emotionen die durch den klimawandel
gerade bei den jungen menschen
hervorgerufen werden
23 jährige jan fleischhauer auch bei
freunden future gewesen mit großer
wahrscheinlichkeit zu erwarten
ich kenne ja es ist eine geschichte über
die du immer erzählt irgendwie so zeigen
wie man aus dem politisch linken heraus
hat irgendwie sozusagen konservativ
geworden ist und deswegen wundert mich
das nicht da würde ich sagen dass meine
position carla du darfst einmal die
rolle des erfahrenen interviews
interviewerin eine als jan auf der couch
akt hat man wieder gemerkt karl hat
eigentlich gar keine lust auf diese
individuellen geschichten einzugehen sie
möchte die große bühne haben hat sich
dann aber darauf eingelassen und auch
mal nachgefragt wie viel ist da jetzt
vielleicht nur fassade und wie viel ist
wirklich echt neue meinung die sich
verändert hat im vergleich zu ganz
vergangenheit gab es im moment tue
persönlich veränderung erlebt hast und
es war
also veränderung ist ja nicht doof ich
habe ja nur zweifel was sozusagen die
veränderungsfähigkeit von einem selbst
angeht und dann natürlich erst recht von
ganzen gesellschaften also man kennt das
doch auch fünf beziehung anfang zu
kriseln dass man großes versprechen
macht also ich würde mich total ändern
also ich bin ein ganz anderer mensch ja
also die frau am weglaufen und
verspricht also alles und du bist ja
auch vor
ein anderer mensch und die schiffe unter
erkenntnis ist er ist gelingt nicht so
ich glaube dass wir wahnsinnig träge
gewesen sind so wenn du über deine
kinder über nachdenkst macht das nichts
mit dir dass du beißt sie werden in der
welt leben die es zweieinhalb drei grad
heißer so das multipliziert die
klimafolgen
macht das nicht noch mal ein anreiz zu
sagen vielleicht kann es noch schaffen
ich glaube ja nicht drin dass ich
glaubte ich darüber total fit wer
fatalistisch
ich hoffe dass wir es besser hinkriegen
mit einer wärmeren welt zu leben wir
werden anders leben du wirst in 50
jahren anders leben wir werden daran
glaube ich auch aus karton wege finden
dann auch mit zum beispiel extremem
wetter besser umzugehen sie werden
anders bauen zum beispiel also guck dir
mal die also so wie in rheinland pfalz
ist es das fachwerkhäuschen wo eine flip
konnten alle da steht nur noch ein 1 1
einen
balken diese art von der bauweise wird
sondern ihm ergeben wir werden das
natürlich anpassen an dann dann eine
veränderte welt und dann müssen uns aber
auch an der welt anpassen der halt jeden
sommer
hunderttausend im zweifelsfall
sterbenden hitzewellen so aufgrund von
temperaturen die nicht mehr aus sagt wir
sind wo wasser gehört also so ist auch
das sind ja also wir können vielleicht
baulich an fluten anpassen das ist meint
wegen dass eine
sonnenschein machen wir nicht mehr
geschweige denn wasser ins grundwasser
das kriegen wir nicht wenn es nicht da
ist es werden hunderttausende von
menschen auch weltweit sterben wenn wir
den natürlich die wohlstandszuwachs
drosseln was der letztlich genau das ist
was gefordert wird
du sollst du sollst uns hier kommen so
und das also in alle alle alle afrika
und in asien wird es sehr sehr viele
menschen geben es sei denn wir wir haben
diese großen traum von was ich fitze
fitze pur oder was
die daneben
sterben werden weil
das weniger gibt habe das gefühl wir
sind jetzt sehr weit weg von dem aber so
oder so dazu gebracht den toten in der
dritten welt es gibt verschiedene arten
nicht erst ich hab nicht von menschen
angesprochen sondern auch hier also auch
hier sehen wir jetzt schon oder werden
die hunderttausende starben egal was ich
mache und das ist ja auch gut so die
beiden haben immer sofort wieder die
argumente von ihrer seite parat und
wollen sich eigentlich die ganze zeit
setzen so wenn man sich jetzt klar macht
ok jeder von den beiden ist voll in
seinem thema voll in seinem metier ist
auch klar dass die ihre argumente kennen
was aber oft bei streitigkeiten und auch
beim diskutieren übersehen wird ist das
ein riesen wert darin liegt auch die
argumente der gegenseite wirklich zu
kennen und wann können wir beweisen dass
wir etwas wirklich kennt wenn wir es
reproduzieren wenn wir es wirklich
selber machen wenn ich selber erklären
kann dann habe ich selber verstand und
deswegen dass sich die beiden jetzt eine
rede halten und zwar mit vertauschten
rollen jan als carla und kann als jan
darauf jetzt kommt noch ein ganz
wichtiger punkt nämlich du redest so
lange lebe ja bis carla klatschte
das gibt es das doch sehr zeitnah
[Musik]
aufgeschlossenes publikum kann
allerdings mit bitteschön the state is
yours
also das war natürlich ganz furchtbar
weil ich bin ja immer winter darauf
gepolt dass ich plötzlich den applaus
meines publikums einheimste
die frage ist wie viel ist uns das klima
wert die frage ist falsch gestellt
wir werden einen punkt kommen wo uns das
was wir heute bezahlen um in einer
einigermaßen funktionierende
erträglichen welt zu leben lächerlich
finden werden weil das was wir einsetzen
müssen schon in wenigen jahren
so gigantisch sein wird dass wir uns
wünschen würden wir hätten zu dem moment
als sie die möglichkeit hatten im jahr
2020 21
ein beitrag zu leisten diesen deal
letztlich angeboten hat eingegangen
wir haben versucht sie an gibt alles und
carla klatscht und klatsch nicht und
stieß allerdings erlöse den arm an aber
sie lässt ihn nicht vom haken
dem stichwort was willst du gerne hören
vielleicht auch 23 wurde sagt dann hat
er mich und das ist eigentlich meine
punkte
politische forderungen und maßnahmen und
wo stehen wir gerade was investieren wir
gerade in falls die energien versus was
geht da noch was ich kann dann würde ich
sagen das ist eine rede die an den
leuten komplett vorbei geht ich hatte
schon das gefühl dass er war schon nicht
verstanden hat wie ich und weil es so
viele glauben dass politischer wandel
funktioniert und wie wir uns auch
sozusagen der klimapolitik vorstellt die
viele leute mitnimmt du bist jetzt aber
kann ja dann hätte ich nicht schlechte
rede jaja über systemische forderung
dass david erhöht kein mensch zu für in
der rede die verkennt was ich eigentlich
gesagt hätte ich eine platte auf unseren
streiks kommen viele leute und die
freuen sich immer wenn wir nicht
übersehen also erreicht die leute die
aber schon eher nicht glauben dann also
ich weiß nicht ich weiß nicht wann die
letzte bewegung mal 1,4 million menschen
auf die straße auch schon wäre ja dann
kam auch pro monat sollte man vielleicht
nicht mehr so viele menschen auf die
straße bringen das ziemlich starke
rückhalt abgebürstet hat ja das hat mich
getroffen
sehr schwierig sich als klima aktivistin
lilian fried schaut
ja was ist uns eigentlich das klima wert
das ist ja schon mal eine falsch
gestellte frage also so das klima das
haben wir ja grundsätzlich so klima
haben wir und es kann immer werden oder
kälter werden aber klima ist ja nicht da
oder nicht da und selbst wenn wir jetzt
klimaschutz maßnahmen ergreifen dann
bleibt das klima nicht weg so also
deswegen ist ja die frage schon mal
falsch gestellt als gesellschaft müssen
wir die pflicht uns fragen wie viel
verzicht sind wir bereits zu üben ist
dieser verzicht dann teuer können sich
dann nur noch reiche das gute leben
leisten wird dann autofahren so teuer
dass es nur noch die leute machen können
die sich ein auto leisten können das
haben wir im vorort kann können dass
alle gerne auch als zweitwagen ich war
in ihrem vortrag natürlich klasse weil
der hat die parodistische qualitäten
aber die krankenschwester mit dem alten
diese elf die immer abhandelt aus dem
vorort nach münchen die kann sich das
neue jahr schon nicht leisten soll sie
dann morgens um fünf wo gar keine bahn
fährt mit wir nicht fahren den bahn
fahren und dann zweieinhalb stunden mit
dem nachtbus ich glaube also das können
wir uns ja also das ist klar so kann das
kann dass sich aussehen ich hatte aber
das gefühl deutlich er sozusagen das
aufzugreifen was er gesagt hat was
akzeptiert an klimapolitik
klimaereignisse werden kommen und darauf
müssen wir uns als gesellschaft
vorbereitet wir müssen uns anpassen wir
müssen unsere gebäude anders bauen wir
müssen unsere infrastruktur
widerstandsfähiger machen wir brauchen
klimaanlagen das ist klar im büro haben
wir ja schon das braucht es dann
vielleicht auch in den wohnhäusern wenn
man drei mal darüber nachdenkt dann
stellt man fest ok so passt es irgendwie
doch vorn und hinten nicht zusammen
deren haus kaufe ich jetzt nicht mehr
ins wie die teilen sondern vielleicht
erst skandinavien
aber es ist ja
könnt ihr euch doch schon länger
keines schlechter wäre das sehr schlecht
aber
wenn der klimawandel kommt dann ist er
bester job bei callas räder hast du
gemerkt dass der fleischer wirklich so
richtig in seinem kinosessel saß und
genossen hat der dachte wirklich wir
sind hier bei der focus weihnachtsfeier
und die erzählt beziehungsweise ich
erzähle da gerade so wunderschön hat
sich riesig gefreut und ich muss ihn ja
tatsächlich erinnern zu klatschen weil
ich glaube dass drei stunden zu wird ich
kann verstehen dass du genießt aber ist
nicht langsamer applaus völlig
fasziniert die frage ist das selbst
verliebt wenn man seinen eigenen
argumenten so gerne gehör schenkt ich
glaube nicht ich glaube dass er
tatsächlich ist unglaublich stattfand
dass sie so krass und auch rhetorisch so
krass vorbringen kann wofür er
eigentlich steht
zwischendurch hatte man das gefühl wird
so richtig energisch macht was mit ihr
die gegenseite mal so zu vertreten ja
und ich verstehe auch manchen punkte
also dass man jetzt sagen zu
veränderungen es irgendwie schwierig und
gesellschaftlich herausfordernd aber das
wird für mich nicht auf dass ich sage
die klimakrise die veränderung die vor
die uns die stellen wird es so viel
schlimmer unserer viel dramatischer das
so dann lieber die gesteuerte
veränderungen die wir selber mitmachen
können
jan ist ohne applaus ab gegangen habe
mir natürlich drückt ja ich hätte auch
nicht mehr genau gewusst
was ich an argumenten bringen soll also
alle versuchen der freilich viel stoff
zum armen nimmst du das außer war ja das
ist ja ganz frisch macht ist die erste
politische bewegung die jugendbewegung
wo die bundeskanzlerin gewissermaßen am
tanz steht und bei packten sie empfängt
in schools alles ist ja eigentlich
dagegen du bist ja auch als freude für
fischer aktivist natürlich gegen diese
regierung die er letztlich nur leere
versprechungen macht und das eine ganz
fiese umarmungsstrategie immer so zu tun
als sei mal auf einer seite tatsächlich
ist es natürlich überhaupt nicht wenn du
an freies for future jetzt mal wirklich
versuchen würde es einen wunsch zu
formulieren der vielleicht von dem
vorwurf aus gilt dieses ihr glaubt der
verzicht regelt aber das tut es nicht
was wäre das 500 das missverständnis in
der frage liegt daran dass wir zusammen
finden nein nein mein prinzip ist ein
widerspruch das ist zu sagen ist das wo
ich auch eine aufgabe sie als kolumnist
das heißt kein millimeter in richtung
eines ich will nicht recht ich versuche
immer zu verstehen also in dem sinn und
nachzuvollziehen wie carla denkt aber
dass wir sozusagen jetzt über den
üblichen regeln uns die hände reichen
weil wir in einem großen gemeinsamen
projekt weiß ich der rettung der
menschheit arbeiten ja wie ich mich
dabei dass ich meine aufgabe verstanden
carla jetzt du jan fleischhauer traut
geschafft keine veränderung zu dein
größter vorwurf an ihn kannst du dir das
in einen wunsch an ihn umformulieren
denn wer meint vielleicht eher
deine eigenen privilegien geht mir ja
gerade angesprochen hast zu hinterfragen
und zu fragen resultiert für dich da
raus vielleicht eine verantwortung doch
irgendwie sozusagen mehr zu tun als
einfach nur sich über die welt uns recht
zu machen ja
ja das freut mich total wert ist
entscheidender punkt hast du recht
absolut
wenn ihr jetzt als pärchen hierhin
gekommen wäre würdet ihr sagen das macht
sinn wir versuchen es weiter oder wir
dann nach heute schluss
die verstellung
traut euch beiden zu sich das zumindest
sehr hypothetisch vorzustellen
also ist es ja immer so wenn man längere
zeit miteinander
verbringt und dem anderen zuhört und ich
völlig vernagelt ist dass man ihn besser
versteht
und er im zweifel auch sympathisch wird
also ich glaube es gab es ein bisschen
bedingungen wo man sagt soll man kann
jetzt noch mal darüber nachdenken wenn
zum beispiel was ich angesprochen habe
jan über seine verantwortung als sehr
privilegierte person was das eigentlich
bedeutet und ob er verantworten kann die
konstruktion dass es jan fleischhauer
des öffentlichen lebens so zu sein wie
er sie ist in den krisenhaften zeiten in
denen wir leben und dann kann man
darüber sprechen so
klingt jetzt nicht mehr liebe um ehrlich
zu sein und trotzdem habe ich das gefühl
auch wenn ihr wieder ganz weit auf dem
sofa auseinandersetzt und stück weit
seid euch näher gekommen ja
und dann danke ich euch wirklich
wirklich von herzen dass ihr hier watt
hierhin gekommen seid euch in dieses
experiment getraut hat so klar für eure
punkte eingetreten seit alles mitgemacht
hat die perspektive getauscht hat und
ich glaube an ganz vielen stellen eine
empathie geschaffen habe für eure
jeweiligen punkte die bei mir noch
ziemlich nachhallen wird vielleicht das
irgendwann mal danke dass ihr da wart
was nämlich aus der sitzung mit also
dann doch den respekt für die
ernsthaftigkeit des engagement
wie wichtig komplett abgeht ich weiß
nicht ob wir uns so viel näher kommen
konnten weil wir eben auf diesen
verschiedenen debatten ebenen
stattfinden er als beobachter von welche
rolle hat die klimabewegung
gesellschaftlich und ich als aktivistin
für klima sie würde sich sicher wünscht
sich dass auch alles ernster nehme
so dass es mir sicherlich nicht gegeben
ich glaube die ganze diskussion ist
immer unglaublich wichtig und richtig
wie jede demokratie auch wenn man
anderer meinung ist immer meine trotzdem
sagen kann ich sehe das anders und ich
finde auch falsch so welcher position
wieder am ende kommt
[Musik]
aber das ist ja diese ernsthaftigkeit
von ihr
auch die wirklich tiefe beschäftigung
mit den dingen
die können sie schon aus wenn wir noch
mal den anfang zurück gehen dann hatten
wir diese couch und die beiden sitzen
maximal weit auseinander so jetzt sind
wir am ende angekommen und die sitzen
immer noch an den beiden entzweiten der
couch das ist aber völlig okay weil für
mich müssen die sich gar nicht die hand
geben geschweige denn sich irgendwie
umarmen darum geht es nicht für mich
ging es heute darum dass die sich
verstehen und ich glaube da sind die
echten schritt gegangen die beiden
werden anders aufeinander gucken nach
dem was wir heute gemacht haben und für
mich war das das größte ziel und ich
glaube das können wir abhaken
das war die erste folge von auf der
couch nicht persönlich bin fast noch ein
bisschen geschwitzt von der ganzen
diskussion und vom streiten aber mir hat
es gefallen ich hoffe euch auch wenn ja
lasst mir leichter und abonniert vor
allem den kanal damit ihr beim nächsten
mal bescheid wissen wenn es eine neue
folge gibt und vielleicht verraten sie
mir sogar noch in den kommentaren und
wer das nächste mal hier auf der couch
bei mir sitzen soll bis dahin force
schaffen